oi oi
[Música]
E aí
e o que você pode dizer sobre mim apenas
me olhando assim basicão apenas pela
minha aparência
Talvez algumas pessoas comecem assim Aí
usa óculos né Então essa é um cara muito
estudioso uma pessoa que lê deve ter
trabalho ali lendo alguma coisa é quem
sabe você pode falar alguma coisa
olhando para mim aparência é que você
consegue olhar e falar sobre mim para
olha para mim agora rapidinho e pensa
as ruas pessoas começaram pelo que elas
vivem seu óbvio né e é um olhar fala
assim bom ele é homem tá com uma roupa
um pouco social ali não é social aliança
de casado na mão esquerda óculos é
provavelmente a religioso Natália usando
os fixo deve trabalhar com leitura a
pele aparentemente não é muito queimada
ao sol então trabalho ao ar livre da
trabalhar dentro de algum gato Professor
casado Professor religioso família de
bem pois é essa seria análise básica né
se não fosse para os pequenos detalhes o
primeiro como vocês podem ver na verdade
esse óculos não tem nem lente né só que
não é nada é tô com um foco de luz aqui
no meu rosto na lateral se você observar
pela reflexo do relógio dá para ver se
fosse realmente um óculos de grau e a
ter uma lente aqui ela seria estaria
refletindo provavelmente a luz tá aqui
do lado a aí tem isso aqui também né
Pois é né esse é um símbolo muito
religioso tem mais ou menos aí o anos
que eu não pratico religião nenhuma esse
curso fixar que eu comprei no camelô
vindo para cá aqui para gravação A então
não isso que a gente fez aqui na verdade
é o que é chamado de manutenção da
aparência a manutenção da aparência é um
termo muito utilizado Principalmente
quando fala se sobre manipulação ou por
exemplo processo de interrogatório não
está realizando o interrogatório muitas
vezes o suspeito tenta passar uma imagem
muito positiva para que as pessoas que
estão interrogando ele ou até mesmo se
ele tiver numa audiência por exemplo
júri interprete ele como uma pessoa
bacana uma pessoa nesta alguém que não
teria feito aquilo mas nada mais é do
que puramente e engana mas se você
observar nem tudo que eu disse nessa
minha análise É de fato 100% mentira de
fatos você observar a minha pele ela
aparentemente não é muito queimada de
sol pode indicar assim que não trabalho
exposto ao ar livre né não trabalho fora
de um local fechado se você não
contrário eu trabalho dentro de um
escritório que eu trabalho com algum
pouco mais intelectual dentro de um
lugar fechado de fato eu sou o
investigador privado e sou perito
judicial trabalho dentro do meu
escritório aqui analisando casos
observando situações mas diferente
dessas pessoas que vem com teorias
mirabolantes
sem validação científica nenhuma dizendo
que é possível você olhar para o rosto
de uma pessoa outra forma do corpo dela
e saber tudo da vida dela eu trabalho e
geralmente respondendo perguntas
perguntas muitas vezes objetivas por
exemplo onde essa pessoa trabalha quem é
essa pessoa será que ela tá traindo o
marido será que ele tá traindo a esposa
e aí para responder eu faço uma pesquisa
coletando evidências acompanho as
pessoas que investigo por alguns dias
registra imagens coleta outras
evidências para dar e responda de forma
conclusiva e objetiva essas perguntas
com sim ou não sim a pressão não não tem
traição Entre várias outras situações é
isso basicamente com o detetive faz mais
o tipo de trabalho nessa forma de lidar
com a minha vida profissional acabou
virando o meio que o modus Operandi da
minha vida pessoal eu vi tu eu acabei
utilizando essa forma de organizar a
mente buscar evidências observar bem a
situação antes de dó decisão no meu dia
a dia você fala assim o que quer ajuda
ajuda muito por exemplo a lembrar onde
você deixou a carteira Onde você deixou
de repente até o celular chave do carro
ou até mesmo você pode utilizar essa
habilidade de observar bem detalhes
fazer Os questionamentos certos
pesquisar muito bem quando você tiver se
relacionando com alguém quem nunca
começou a se relacionar com alguém
passou aquele momento ali inicial da
Paixão estava super feliz até que um
belo dia foi descobrir que estava sendo
traído estava sendo traída não é tem uma
situação dessa só resta lhe recorrer às
drogas né o álcool e as músicas
sertanejas mais enfim é o fato é essa
forma de pensar do que a gente costuma
falar que é o pensamento mais lógico ou
a lógica fria a não só é utilizada não
tem apenas a sua serventia em situações
triviais como por exemplo lembrar onde
você deixou um objeto mas ela pode ser
aplicada em contextos onde o resultado
da sua a sua aprovação enfim o resultado
daquela situação o desfecho depende da
sua performance como você vai ser
avaliado socialmente por exemplo uma
entrevista de emprego uma conversa muito
importante uma ligação uma reunião uma
abordagem de vendas por exemplo e vai
depender dessa interação social do seu
desempenho nessa interação para que você
obtenha sucesso é aí que muitas vezes a
gente utiliza o pensamento lógico
principalmente para conseguir observar
situações ver o que que tá acontecendo
de fato não ficar ali sofrendo sofrendo
sofrendo porque se você vai no piloto
automático né no nosso modo instintivo
outros contextos onde você terá uma
interação social sinto lhe dizer mas na
maioria da e vai cometer enganos tá com
fome morre ao seu levantou é com ele e
outros pesquisadores já nos mostraram a
capacidade humana sem treinamento
adequado para avaliar uma situação em
tempo real e julgar se está sendo ou não
enganado é de cinquenta por cento ou
seja se você for no seu modo intuitivo
em todas as situações a capacidade do
seu sucesso numa performance ele numa
interação social equivale a jogar uma
moeda para cima tirar no carro por isso
que é muito importante
lembrar-se sempre de fazer perguntas
questionar e analisar a situação não
tentar sempre promocional não tentar
sempre para o intuitivo esse é o nosso
Nosso principal objetivo aqui hoje eu
sim inclusive alguns pontos que a
própria psiquiatra a norte-americana
Mariah konnikova mostras seus trabalhos
ela disse que uma forma de exercitar
esse lado mais crítico nosso cérebro
ficar cada vez menos ligado no nosso
piloto automático é fazer perguntas e
muitas vezes a gente simplesmente sai
aceitando tudo que é falado a gente nem
questiona fala fala para sempre chegar
no lugar numa situação e olhar o
contexto e o cenário em volta começar a
fazer perguntas olha só que cobra aquele
Quem deixou aquele copo ali Será que eu
tenho alguma evidência de que deixou
aquele copo quantas quantos objetos da
cor vermelha eu vejo nesse cenário agora
quando o objeto está cor azul e por aí
vai isso torna cada vez mais o seu modo
crítico ativo na sua mente você ficar
cada vez menos no seu piloto automático
a e esse método de fazer perguntas foi
basicamente o que me salvou de entrar
numa catástrofe numa das minhas
principais entrevistas de emprego até
hoje ela aconteceu alguns anos atrás e
eu lembro que eu tava com muito muito
muito medo que você ficar muito nervoso
Especialmente quando eu olhei para o
rosto ali do meu entrevistador e eu
tinha certeza que ele estava odiando a
entrevista eu tinha certeza que eu ia
bombar e naquele momento naquela época
tinha todos os motivos possíveis ali em
todas as justificativas emocionais para
me sentir daquele jeito e naquele
momento eu era uma pessoa anônimo e o
assunto linguagem corporal Não era nem
tão assim tão comentado e muito menos
comentado de forma séria era sempre algo
então dirá truque de mágica Eu lembro
quando essa pessoa viu falar comigo e me
chamou no retrocesso para conversar
falei meu Deus o que está acontecendo
aqui era ninguém mais ninguém menos que
Maurício Meirelles um dos maiores
comediantes da atualidade nos maiores
comediantes brasileiros era uma figura
muito famosa Eu não fazia ideia que que
ela queria falar comigo né eu era da
linguagem corporal e da era da comédia
mesmo assim estou com uma ideia e ele me
queria para conversar com ele para tomar
um café lá na empresa dele eu topei eu
aceitei e eu fiquei ansioso veja bem
ansiedade ela alá uma sensação natural
do corpo humano tá certo é algo normal o
problema é quando a gente não consegue
ter controle da sociedade ou quando ela
acaba gerando umas o pensamento zíper
catastróficos para o nosso futuro a
gente conversa mais no futuro e só vai
acontecer coisa ruim não tem como você
controlar o futuro falar vai acontecer
isso o que você pode entrar buscar por
evidências para te ajudar a entender a
situação que você está naquele momento
quando eu chamei nephu chamada
promotores emprego eu coloquei em
prática exatamente o que eu faço fui
pesquisar levantar dados e evidentemente
quando você começa precisar muito você
acaba achando mais coisas eu tenho no
momento eu acabei vendo ali um outro
outra personalidade configurar chamada
Caio que era sócio do Maurício Meirelles
na empresa deles vai ser a pesquisar
sobre o Caio também Vi que
Diferentemente de modo de férias eu caio
era uma figura muito mais carrancudo
nada e era um cara bem mais fechado bem
mais na dele não era até um dispositivo
tão brincalhão com Maurício mesmo assim
eu pensei cara é melhor até algo em
mente casa ou vai conversar com esse
Caio melhorou está preparado ou seria o
conversando com alguém se não gosta do
meu assunto que não tem conhecimento
sobre o assunto como que eu faria isso E
aí eu comecei a ensaiar pequenas
abordagens em casa bom Oi bom dia eu fui
para a empresa tava lá 20 minutos
adiantado na frente da empresa vai
adiantar do horário que a gente chama
Cadu Aliexpress me fala o cara manda uma
mensagem eu tô meio enrolado aqui vai
subindo aí vai conversando com meu
pessoal com a equipe falei Opa Tudo bem
pediu elevado conforme solicitou subir
comprimentei um dos sócios do Maurício
Meirelles cheguei na sala de reuniões
ele sentei e na minha frente para minha
surpresa estava quem ele mesmo o sócio
Caio na posição de grande Don Corleone
me esperando ali para reunião fica seu
julgamento da minha alma para falar a
verdade eu mal sentei observei linguagem
corporal dele ele estava com o notebook
dele na frente dele né do corpo dele
entre eu e ele notebook na mesa ele é
uma pequena olhada para mim olhou e
falou assim que que você faz mesmo sendo
a comediante né estamos a conversar e aí
sim eu comecei a sua frio começava a
falar um pouco aqui e ele demonstrava
nas reações negativas e fazer os
comentários do tipo armas o que você faz
não é muito legal eu te amo vejo muita
coisa mesmo mesmo para graça e eu
percebi que eu tava começando a ficar
nervoso né eu comecei a observar
comportamentos faciais nele por exemplo
micro expressões de desprezo é é uma
micro inspiração para quem não está
familiarizado desde a década de 60 a
gente obteve evidências nas pesquisas
entre outras nacionalidades a inclusive
sobre civilizações não entradas como por
exemplo de papua-nova guiné acerta a
tribo dos fóruns e civilizações entradas
orientais e ocidentais o comportamento
facial nessas civilizações e forma
teoria inclusive proposta por Charles
Darwin há mais de 100 anos e pesquisada
por vários pesquisadores desde a década
de 60 entende-se que Independente se
você está numa civilização não entrada
no Oriente o acidente ou não a
civilização letrada o seu comportamento
facial quando você sente uma emoção é o
mesmo as micro expressões faciais
universais vencer universais são inatas
tanto que pesquisas feitas com pessoas
cegas de nascer e até São mesmo
comportamento espacial de pessoas que
não são cegas ou Experimente e também me
tratando de um período facial porque eu
tenho certificação na área das micro
expressões faciais eu sempre analiso as
pessoas naquele dia eu analisava o
comportamento espacial momentâneo do
Caio e via desprezo veja bem estava numa
situação aí eu tava ficando bem ansioso
era um interesse de emprego super
importante então era um cara normal
tentando crescer no início da carreira
aquela entrevista era muito importante
então era natural que eu começasse a ter
pensamentos catastróficos Associados a
minha pessoa aí ele me odeia esse
entrevistador ele não gosta de mim eu
reprovei eu mandei mal é certo e tal
nesse momento a gente tem que ter uma
visão em terceira pessoa tentar sair ali
do cenário e olhar a situação por cima
quando eu fiz isso né porque eu pensei
assim pera aí o quê que eu não estou
fazendo aqui
e eu não estou fazendo perguntas lembra
que eu falei lá no começo o que que você
pode falar sobre me olhando para mim
aparece a gente tem sempre que cultivar
o hábito de criar perguntas teve uma
dificuldade vão tentar responder essa
dificuldade querendo perguntas um buscar
dados para responder essa dificuldade
esse problema aqui no momento eu comecei
a criar perguntas eu pensei assim esse
cara tá me tratando assim essa maneira
meio ríspida com essas expressões
desprezo Porque ele não gosta de mim ou
tem alguma outra motivação aí eu tentei
pensar falei bom ele é sócio da empresa
faria sentido ele ter esse comportamento
sendo sócio para tentar ao máximo
preservar empresa dele dica de manter
relações com pessoas que não vão trazer
benefício para ele pensei sim Faria na
sequência pessoa outra pergunta então
será que não faria sentido reagir assim
com qualquer pessoa que ele entrevista
aqui nessa sala de reuniões eu pensei
sim faria sentido logo cheguei a
conclusão ele não está meio tratando mal
ele não está tratando o Victor mal
porque ele não gostou do e essa apenas o
comportamento operando em modo aprende
dele com o empresário Tá certo tá apenas
o modus Operandi dele para fechar uma
negociação para a empresa dele não é
nada pessoal não é nada comigo e quando
eu tive esse Insight eu Relaxei isso é
muito mais tranquilo quando a gente tem
esse momento de questionamento é sempre
interessante Direcionar para onde você
quer continuar sua pensamento quando eu
fechei essa ideia falei bom já que não é
comigo Qual é o foco do meu pensamento
agora não tem como não concentrar nesse
momento eu dei a situação e pensei não
precisa ser igual de mim não
discriminando o dia que eu preciso eu
preciso conseguir criar um ra porcos
preciso conseguir criar uma conexão
emocional preciso conseguir criar
empatia o que que eu posso fazer outra
pergunta que eu fiz naquele momento
enquanto eu conversava com ele eu fiz
uma breve recapitulação nossa conversa
falei bom neste começou a nossa conversa
eu tô falando de artigo científico eu tô
mostrando evidências em livros eu tô
falando uma de coisa e ele tá só com uma
cara de tédio uma expressão aí de que
não está realmente interessado talvez eu
devo mudar me abordarem e foi assim site
que eu tive Aconteceu algo muito bacana
eu cometi depois da tecido esse
pensamento ele me perguntou algo técnico
expliquei uma expressão facial ao evento
na fase que ocorre de maneira breve etc
e quando a 10 explicação técnica ele fez
exatamente isso comportamento aqui a
muito legal Vitor
e foi então que eu olhei para ele falei
assim não não você não achou muito legal
Caio você falou muito legal porém fez um
afastamento corporal a micro negação de
cabeça cruzou os braços e fez um amigo
expressão de desprezo seu comportamento
não-verbal de exatamente o oposto do que
você acabou de falar você disse muito
legal mas não sou linguagem corporal não
disse a mesma coisa provavelmente você
não tá achando legal desse jeito Não
quando eu falei isso arregalou os olhos
assim olhou para o outro funcionário que
estava ali na porta na nossa sala de
reunião deu uma baita risada foi Putz
era isso mesmo cara como que você devia
a roda eu tô achando mesmo cara porque
legal então isso que você faz aí ele
percebeu que eu fazia nesse momento Ele
já tirou um notebook da frente do corpo
dele entrei e ele se debruçou na mesa
pegou mesmo foi o cara muito bacana Por
que legal então é assim que funciona tal
comecei com ele ali a gente ficou bem
ali é sincronizado ele gostou bastante
deu bastante risada alguns minutos
depois entra mauris e na sala dizendo
assim agora você não vai ver na minha
analisar Victor
metaforando.com um saco de pão na cabeça
é
aquele foi um dia muito bacana são de
aumento importante é ter passado por
esse evento por essa experiência ter
tido a chance de colocar em prática a
minha forma de pensamento né que é uma
forma que eu curto e vem na minha
profissão como detetive só que eu mais
importante ali na minha opinião foi o
desfecho Porque além da ter ganhado uma
baita amizade né me tornei amigo do Mal
Maurício Meirelles bem vários ensaios
sobre carreira na sobrevida
filosofia-de-vidas eu tive uma baita de
nada na minha carreira profissional e
tudo isso se deu por conta de um
desfecho positivo e se desfez Positivo
foi durante uma entrevista de emprego na
costa Quem muito ansioso muito nervoso
mas eu consegui remanejar Tá certo ali
perceber que estava acontecendo fiz as
perguntas corretas tirei o meu pessoal
né Ai pessoal vai comigo não não fiz
aquele funcionamento mais frio possível
por meio da análise Da Lógica consegui
determinar o desfecho que eu queria
Então o meu ponto principal é sempre
focar e se observou Algo Se eu tiver um
detalhe só tenho fatos sobre aquilo
acerto quais evidências Eu tenho
educação do falado não se orientar pelas
pelo emocional apenas por aquela
primeira impressão que a gente dele
porque muitas vezes a gente costuma
falhar teve um exemplo Provavelmente
quando você viu aqui o começo da minha
apresentação Você viu que eu tirei no
óculos mostrei que na verdade era um
óculos que não era o óculos era um mero
adereço Eu nem uso óculos só que eu
tirei a aliança e não fale absolutamente
lado muito pensaram que a verdade eu não
sou nem casado
Olá eu sou casado e no momento que eu tô
aqui a quando inclusive quando eu tava
vindo para cá eu tava conversando com a
minha esposa e a gente lembrou e Como
que foi o começo nosso namoro e eu tô a
precisa terminar com ela a gente tinha
dois três meses de namoro eu tinha
certeza que ela simplesmente não gostava
do nosso relacionamento que ela não
estava confortável ela não responde às
mensagens de bom dia não tinha um
comportamento assim está querendo sempre
conversar era muito quieta e eu lembro
que houve um dos pontos principais foi
quando um dia ela foi fazer uma consulta
no médico e ela perdeu a aliança dela de
namorada chama nas de namoro eu lembro
que eu falei poxa lá perdeu a linha
cinema e contou cara foi descobrir uma
semana depois falei que eu acho que
realmente ela tá meio desinteressada
pensando refletindo péssimo E se ela na
verdade foi uma pessoa tímida
e na verdade foi uma coisa dela não fala
muito sobre isso ela não me falou da
Aliança porque ela ficou com vergonha
não sabia como falar e aí eu fiz um
acordo mental falei vou passar observar
ela e ficar com menos esse conceito na
minha cabeça vou tirar esse conceito
pessoal e vou observar os fatos vou ver
o que faço eu tenho sobre ela e ali
naquela época eu percebi que ela não só
não se comunicavam com ninguém lá não se
comunicavam direito com as amigas dela
não tinham um sistema um ecossistema de
comunicação com os familiares dela com
os pais ou seja era realmente muito
tímida acerto de fato ela depois me
contou que a aliança foi porque ela
perdeu e ficou com muita vergonha de
falar cinco meses depois desse meu
pensamento a gente ainda tava namorando
né E ela já tinha conversado comigo
várias vezes e ela decidiu se abre para
mim e ela chorou e falou olha você é a
primeira pessoa que me entende eu sempre
fiquei com vergonha sempre fui tímida
nunca consegui conversar com ninguém
você é a primeira pessoa consigo
conversar eu tinha acertado a minha
dedução sobre ela 17 anos depois nós
estamos casados e a nossa primeira filha
nas a Laurinha tá aí fazendo aniversário
de 4 meses então a lição que eu tiro
disso tudo é lição colega para a vida é
não confie sem por cento nas impressões
que você tem emocionais sobre
determinada situação elas podem te
enganar busca por evidências e busque
avaliar a situação com base em Fatos e
não apenas com base em emoções era isso
que eu tinha para dizer muito obrigado
E aí